gli altri vuoti inutili divisi per
etichette categor
lì e pubblico
il settore
fatti da gente del settore con gente del
settore e poco sentore tutto sempre
uguale fondi pubblici mal distribuiti
soppressione di enti inutili scioperi
del made accise sulla benzina attori
senza diari e sussidio di disoccupazione
stabili con buchi di bilancio direttori
scelti perché piacciono alla mamma del
sindaco molta tutela del diritto
d'autore
nessun rispetto dei saperi delle
maestranze e dell'intelligenza del
pubblico burocrati ben saldi artisti
senza soldi politica del grande evento
teatro della miseria manca l'epica manca
la crudeltà manca dioniso e fu così che
un giorno di giugno si occupa un teatro
del 1727 per attuare una rivolta
culturale
buonasera a tutti
questa sera ci dicono che si parla di
rivoluzioni sostenibili e noi altra
trovarle crediamo che le rivoluzioni non
solo devono essere sostenibili ma devono
essere anche fatte del banco insomma
incominciare ad essere messe in campo
insomma già incominciare a tirare fuori
un po di coraggio e fare le rivoluzioni
a casa tra le piccole cose tra le grandi
cose noi stasera vi proviamo a
raccontare le rivoluzioni che stiamo
provando a fare nel nostro piccolo al
teatro valle rita trovare un teatro
storico antico del settecento
un dato importante che sta nel centro di
roma sta a 200 metri dal senato sta in
mezzo a quei palazzi la così vuoti di
significato ormai quei palazzi di potere
abitati da fantasmi ed è un po la spina
del fianco di quei palazzi 14 giugno del
2011 i lavoratori e lavoratrici dello
spettacolo nel deciso di occupare il
teatro valle
perché
lo stato l'amministrazione i nostri
amministratori quelli che siamo andati a
votare avevano abbandonato questo teatro
antico lo avevano dismesso probabilmente
lo privatizza vano probabilmente non si
sa che fine faceva i lavoratori mandati
macchinisti che da 20 anni lavoravano al
teatro valle ha mandati a lavorare i
ministeri o un po assurdi che non si
capiva e così noi abbiamo detto no non
si può fare è inconcepibile questa cosa
al teatro valle mozart a rossini hanno
portato alle loro opere pirandello i sei
personaggi in cerca d'autore hanno
esordito al teatro valle così noi
abbiamo detto no non può essere
privatizzato non si può vendere un bene
comune non si può vendere un bene
pubblico come il teatro valle l'abbiamo
occupato però cosa vuol dire occupare
occupare certo vuol dire protestare vuol
dire mettersi in opposizione vuol dire
essere antagonisti ma per noi occupare
ha voluto subito dire un'altra cosa ha
voluto dire proviamo a costruire
proviamo a proporre proviamo che questa
occupazione diventa altro che siano
occupazione aperta che diventa una fase
costituente costituita una fase
propositiva e così attori registi
scrittori tecnici maestranze fonici
montatori organizzatori si sono trovati
hanno deciso che non erano solo artisti
ma diventavano anche attivisti che
diventavano protagonisti ecco questo è
il primo punto che il teatro valle qua
questa sera ma insomma da un anno lo sta
dicendo c'è bisogno di protagonismo c'è
bisogno insomma di diventare
protagonisti di noi stessi protagonisti
per noi occupare vuol dire occuparsi di
noi stessi occuparsi di ciò che è nostro
se noi facciamo il cinema facciamo
teatro vuol dire che occupare un teatro
è giusto come è giusto che gli operai
occupano le fabbriche quando chiudono le
fabbriche
tanto per restare in tema
con la regione e arte e politica per noi
sono dispositivi che insieme possono
esplodere fare rivoluzioni arte politica
sono facce della stessa medaglia
arte politica arte politica due sembra
che non c'entrino niente per noi invece
c'entrano tantissimo e su questo vi
volevo far ascoltare una piccola poesia
di bertold brecht è breve quindi ce la
possiamo fare il peggiore analfabeta e
la malfa beta politico e lì non sente
non parla né si interessa degli
avvenimenti politici e lì non sa che il
costo della vita
il prezzo dei fagioli del pesce della
farina dell'affitto delle scarpe delle
medicine dipendono dalle decisioni
politiche
la analfabeta politico e così somaro che
si vanta si gonfia il petto dicendo che
odia la politica non sa l'imbecille che
dalla sua ignoranza politica nasce a
prostituta
il bambino abbandonato la saltante è il
peggiore di tutti i banditi che è il
politico imbroglione il mafioso il
corrotto il lacchè delle imprese
nazionali e multinazionali
il peggiore all'alfa beta el analfabeta
politico ci ricorda brecht e noi del
teatro valle non solo
condividiamo la sottolineamo questa
poesia la scriviamo e la portiamo in
giro perché ci hanno fatto disinnamorare
della politica ci hanno fatto credere
che la politica è brutta e arrenda che
c'è l'antipolitica no la politica siamo
noi sono le nostre vite noi ci dobbiamo
occupare delle nostre vite
adesso però secondo momento
andiamo a vedere volevo un po dirvi cosa
noi stiamo facendo al teatro valle anche
un po proprio elencando i punti che per
noi sono un po rivoluzionario ovviamente
partendo dal teatro perché quello
abbiamo occupato allora per noi uno il
teatro deve ridiventare quello che era
una volta il teatro non
si andava a vedere uno spettacolo così a
caso il teatro una volta era una scelta
di vita è una scelta sociale era vita
sociale per cui per noi il teatro e il
teatro valle occupato tutto quest'anno è
stato un teatro aperto 24 ore dalla
mattina alla sera non c'è basta con
questi teatri che aprono alle 8 e
chiudono alle 11 quando va via la gente
no il teatro deve diventare agorà deve
diventare laboratorio culturale politico
deve diventare una porta spalancata la
città è questo che il vale sta tentando
di fare una porta spalancata alla città
un laboratorio permanente di idee di
scontro di confronto eccetera 2 il
teatro per noi e mescolanza di generi e
mescolanza di arti mescolare alto e
basso non esiste nomi famosi e non
famosi non esistono si mescolano non per
livellare ma per comunicare per mettere
insieme creiamo crediamo in un teatro
un'arte che non sia competitiva vogliamo
smettere di pensare di immaginare che
l'arte la cultura debba nascere in
ambienti competitivi
l'arte la cultura deve essere
cooperazione e collaborazione è più
bello fare i lavori in gruppo 4 la
cultura l'arte per noi e su questa cosa
non sindachiamo non torniamo indietro
per noi l'arte la cultura è un bisogno
primario è un bene comune è come
l'istruzione è come la sanità sognare
cantare parlare viveur immaginare e
calpestare questo palco fare film fare
spettacoli per noi è un bisogno primario
e noi le affermiamo con forza deve
essere una forza e un bisogno primario è
veramente questa è la nostra idea forte
che la cultura l'arte debba tornare al
centro del progetto uomo deve tornare al
centro dell'essere uomo 5 la cultura per
fare questo deve essere diffusa
accessibile
politica e sui prezzi politiche sulla
formazione per noi questi sono cavalli
di battaglia 30 anni stanno costruendo
profitto sulla cultura sesto la cultura
deve essere fuori dal mercato noi
ideologicamente fuori dal mercato ma
fuori dai profitti del mercato perché la
cultura l'arte è un bene comune vedere
un film è un bene comune vedere uno
spettacolo è un bene comune
quindi non può essere logiche di
profitto non può essere logiche di
mercato ma hanno detto che non potevo
leggere però chi se ne frega delle
regole di tex scusa a daniele settimo il
teatro aperto 24 ore vuol dire che noi
crediamo fortemente nella formazione la
formazione deve essere permanente
perpetua costante ma non la formazione
cioè non basta informare bisogna formare
non bastano gli episodi non basta sapere
quando e nato cristoforo colombo noi
intendiamo formazione come trasmissione
dei saperi come trasmissione delle
esperienze
la formazione è centrale negli esseri
umani e bisogna ricominciare a formare
da dentro alle pance da quando una donna
incinta bisogna ricominciare dagli asili
nido a formare un'altra idea di
formazione
abbiamo in mente che è appunto legata
alla trasmissione dei saperi 8
partecipazione e questo è il dato
fondamentale che non è quella roba si
vogliono far credere partecipazione così
tanto per essere un po più fighi e
partecipazione attiva e partecipazione
vera e cittadinanza attiva vera dentro i
teatri denti cinema degli spazi
culturali dentro a tutti gli spazi
questa è la rivoluzione tutto questo per
noi si chiama bene comune e su questo vi
volevo volevamo fare vedere
un video di bergonzoni che col suo
linguaggio assurdo di cui non si capisce
un cazzo
parla di bene comune qui
ti voglio bene comune ma visto così
sembrerebbe un gesto d'amore nei
confronti di qualcosa di troppo
amministrativo esistono dei beni comuni
e dei beni pubblici
qual è il mezzo qual è il fine io
intendo anche come finezza non solo come
morte allora vuole dire che deve morire
qualche cosa a cui vuoi bene per far
contento il comune fondare fondazione
rifondare fondamenta non rifondazione
diciamo soltanto bene e non è un
giudizio di merito non è merito non è
meritocrazia non è giudizio e quindi la
fondazione con una f sole è una forma
navale di qualche cosa che deve stare su
come mai siamo arrivati qua così ormai
sono arrivati là così non possiamo più
arrivare qua e là così vorrei che queste
cose fossero dette prescindere dal dirlo
vorrei che queste cose si stessero a
prescindere dall esistere anche prima
del poterle pensare quindi il tema del
impensato dell'udito d'indicibile
dell'incommensurabile non è possibile
che la parola teatro se gli tolgono ad
altri 20 tetro allora io penso che si
possa arrivare in orizzonti che noi non
vediamo né verticalmente e
orizzontalmente il tema non è né
culturale né artisti che non è neanche
un tema è qualcosa di molto di più se si
riuscisse con una fondazione a parlare
di questo molto di più costantemente io
non sarei felice ma sarei entusiasta
bene adesso la questione si fa un po più
seria perché è tutto quello che ho detto
è capire poi come si fa
e poi capire cosa realmente stiamo
tentando di fare al teatro valle
allora è un progetto è un progetto un po
in effetti è un po un po alto un po però
noi siamo messi in testa che l'unica
l'unica soluzione in questo momento sia
di creare veramente qualcosa di
alternativo qualcosa di oltre di
qualcosa che superi la dicotomia tra
pubblico e privato cioè di provare a
inventare modelli giuridici economici
sociali relazionali diversi per questo
siamo partiti da due analisi che che
sono le nostre analisi ovviamente con
cui non ho insomma possiamo anche
discuterne però noi crediamo che siamo
arrivati a un punto di non ritorno che
il sistema economico che
da tantissimo tempo ma che negli ultimi
30 anni
sta andando contro un muro che è un
sistema neoliberista non abbia più senso
un sistema neoliberista che pensa che le
risorse naturali siano infinite e che si
possono sfruttare all'infinito senza
avere un rapporto con la natura
un sistema che crede che l'uomo possa
essere dominatore delle risorse naturali
crediamo che sia un sistema fallimentare
e che che sta arrivando al fallimento
crediamo che un sistema che che l'unica
soluzione è l'unico paradigma l'unico
dogma che ha è quella della accumulare
all'infinito accumulare non si sa più
neanche cosa non abbia più senso
e questa è una cosa il secondo elemento
di analisi crediamo che anche il sistema
di democrazia rappresentativa
il sistema del pubblico il sistema del
voto il sistema della delega con cui noi
ogni volta con fiducia andiamo a votare
anche quello ormai è fallimentare è
ormai è sulla bocca di tutti
lo dicono tutti che il sistema della
rappresentanza democratica ha fallito
però noi non vogliamo fare antipolitica
non vogliamo non occuparsi di ciò che è
nostro e allora come si fa
noi crediamo che si possa creare che si
possono creare delle forme alternative
delle forme di istituzioni del comune
alternative
credo che crediamo che comunità che si
ritrovano
cittadinanza che si ritrova e che si
auto governa che si auto organizza è che
si incomincia ad interessare di ciò che
il nostro possa reinventare una forma
democratica più forte noi al teatro
valle stiamo appunto trasformando quel
teatro è un bene comune
cosa vuol dire non è solo una parola non
è solo filosofia e trasformazione
giuridica è trasformare giuridicamente
quel posto
noi vogliamo togliere lo stiamo
togliendo quel posto da l'idea che
esista solo la proprietà privata o la
proprietà pubblica
esistono altri modelli giuridici che
ancora non ci sono ma che l'articolo 43
della costituzione o che
il senso comune porta e c'è la il fatto
che della cittadinanza dei lavoratori si
ritrovano sul posto organizzano
gestiscono abbiano lo trattano meglio
quel posto del privato e del pubblico
il pubblico perché è semplicemente che
il pubblico
l'abbiamo troppo lasciato in mano ai
politici che hanno trattato tutti i beni
comuni
i beni pubblici come interessi privati
quindi noi crediamo fortemente che ci
possa essere un'alternativa
noi abbiamo stiamo costruendo una
fondazione una fondazione a uno
strumento tutti possono diventare soci
del teatro valle è una fondazione ad
azionariato diffuso con 10 euro si
diventa soci è un esperimento non
sappiamo come andrà però sicuramente
questo esperimento è una forma di
democrazia diretta è una forma
alternativa di democrazia è una forma
altra di democrazia rispetto a la nostra
scheda elettorale che andiamo a mettere
abbiamo scritto uno statuto credo che
tempo sto
vabbè lo statuto non potete andare
ledger sul nostro sul nostro sito
abbiamo lavorato con dei giuristi
abbiamo elaborato uno statuto per come
gestire un bene comune per come
democratizzare un bene comune però
quello che vogliamo dire forte dal
teatro valle è di da una parte difendere
i beni comune adesso monti sta vendendo
tutto sta privatizzando tutto si si
parla di privatizzare spiagge torrenti
boschi
ormai stiamo vendendo qualsiasi cosa noi
crediamo che invece si debba essere una
difesa dei beni comuni e una riconquista
dei beni comuni credo che cittadinanze
credo che crediamo che ci si possa
ritrovare si dei principi comuni ho
finito come cambia i destini siamo
occupati versione ps e cc accorsi col
plotone prima di sgomberarli sgomberate
vi il cervello